bonsoir Sophie bonsoir les mots me
manquent pour décrire la chronique de ce
soir alors il en existe au BAMO 1
million d'espèces un chiffre qui serait
certainement sous-estimé et qui augmente
chaque année ils sont nécessaires pour
la biodiversité et pour l'ONU il serait
une solution pour lutter contre la fin
dans le monde vous faites très bien
Julien le alors vous avez deviné je vous
laisse dévoiler rép il s'agit bien des
insectes alors voilà pour parler de ce
sujet nous avons ce plateau avec nous
Samuel jolivé vous êtes président de
l'OPI qui est l'office pour les insectes
et leur
environnement vous allez donc nous
parler de ça parce que vous faites des
portes ouvertes dimanche prochain mais
d'abord pour qu'on se rende bien compte
les insectes sont c'est c'est les
animaux sont nos amis peut-être ou c'est
les animaux les plus nombreux dans le
monde en fait il y en a 80 % des animaux
sont des insectes c'est ça en gros oui
c'est ça les les insectes forment
l'écrasante majorité de la biodiversité
animale mal et c'est quand on est en
face de chiffres comme ça 40000 espèces
en France alors que on a à peine 300
espèces d'oiseaux de nicheur qu'on se
rend compte de de l'importance qu'ils
peuvent avoir dans l'écosystème et le
poids qu'ils ont dans la biodiversité
est-ce qu'on sait combien il y a
d'individus par exemple en France ou
dans le monde d'individus non c'est les
insectes on peut pas on peut pas
réfléchir en terme d'individus on
réfléchi en terme de population parce
qu'une une seule mouche par exemple va
pouvoir pondre des milliers d'œuf qui
vont donner naissance à des milliers de
larves et bon au final bien sûr au fur
et à mesure de la croissance des Lares
va y avoir un écrémage naturel avec la
la sélection et et la prédation mais on
peut pas raisonner en terme d'individus
avec les insectes c'est c'est la grosse
différence qu'il y a entre les les
insectes et les vertébrés reste des
animaux d'accord donc vous êtes là parce
que lors de la Fête de la Nature qui
commence demain qui finit dimanche vous
allez organiser les portes ouvertes de
l'OPIE euh et puis même pendant toute la
période là de la Fête de la Nature vous
avez organisé plusieurs ateliers vous
vous ouvrez au grand public est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en parler un petit peu
oui tout à fait donc la la Fête de la
Nature c'est la 7e édition cette année
c'est une grande opération nationale qui
regroupe tous toutes les bonnes volontés
qui participent à la protection de la
nature en France donc nous on est un des
partenaires nationaux de de cette Fête
de la Nature cette année la thématique
c'est cherchons la petite bête donc vous
imaginez bien qu'on est est
particulièrement investi autour du sujet
euh donc là à l'écran s'affiche les
rendez-vous qu'on propose à
Saint-Quentin et dans les les communes
alentours ou donc c'est surtout des
balades en fait c'est ça on va
cherchertit c'est des balades
découvertes avec des des spécialistes
qui sont dé chargés d'études ou des
animateurs de de l'OPI qui vont amener
le public à découvrir qui les insectes
aquatique qui les libellules qui les
papillons nocturnes il y aura une chasse
nocturne au au étend de la minunière le
vendredi soir ça veut dire quoi une
chasse nocturne il vous al une chasse
nocturne on utilise pas du tout de fusil
ni rien ni rien de ce genre-là on met
une grosse lampe en route dans une
prairie et les insectes sont attirés par
la lumière donc ils viennent se
concentrer sur un Dra blanc qui a été
posé au sol et du coup on peut les
observer parce que ils sont ils sont pas
très pas très mobiles une fois qu'ils
ont atterri près de la source lumineuse
et donc l'animateur qui est là peut
expliquer la la vie de de ces petite
bête d'accord c'est quoi le rôle tout au
long de l'année de l'OPI alors l'OPI bah
c'est une association de protection de
la nature et de l'environnement comme il
en existe beaucoup en France nous notre
spécificité c'est d'étudier que les
insectes comme notre nom l'indique et
puis bon vous avez pu comprendre qu'on a
déjà bien assez de travail avec eux et
donc on a on a un rôle et pédagogique là
on voit effectivement des des
présentations de
vivarium je sais plus où c'était
peut-être c'était peut-être la Maison de
l'Environnement cette cette exposition
donc que notre animatrice présente avec
des insectes vivants qui sont très très
spectaculaires c'est des insectes
tropicaux je tiens de préciser on n pas
ça dans nos
jardins on a aussi un rôle important
d'expertise et et d'études de la faune
sauvage et de veille sur les espèces
protégées alors oui on on participe le
ministère de l'Environnement nous a
confié les plans nationaux d'action
autour des insectes donc un sur les
Bellule et un sur un groupe de papillons
qui s'appelle les maculinéa donc c'est
un groupe de papillons qui a une
biologie assez particulière et qui est
très intéressant dans la gestion des des
milieux et donc qui existe ici à
Saint-Quentin non pas pas
d'espèce pas pas ces espèces là c'est
quand même des espèces qui sont liées à
des milieux naturels très très
particuliers en île-de-fance on n pas de
maculinéa donc le plan national d'action
est pas décliné en île- de France par
contre des libellules il y en a
à rouiller il y a certains certaines
espèces concernées par ce d'cord alors
les insectes on peut les observer on
peut les protéger puis on peut aussi les
manger parfois quelle drôle d'idée et
oui 2,5 milliards de personnes le font
déjà dans le monde et en France 37 % des
gens se disent prêt à éventuellement en
manger nous on a été rencontré un
traiteur à trappe qui a décidé de se
lancer dedans de voir si ça pouvait
marcher je propose de voir ça en
image
nous ne sommes pas dans les cuisines
d'un restaurant mais le chef lui est un
professionnel au menu ce midi gambass
flambé au pastiss betraf choga piraya et
lanti corille en fin de compte c'est
vraiment un mélange de couleur et de de
saveur c'est vraiment un plat fusion
quoi fusion comprenez le mélange de
produits et de cuisine de différents
pays migel est traiteur à domicile
depuis 5 mois il cuisine sous l'œil
attentif de l'te et de ses
invités
c'est mais le truc de Miguel aujourd'hui
c'est un ingrédient surprise
donc des
grillons et oui des grillons une
évidence dans les pays d'Asie du Sud-Est
d'Afrique une excentricité en Europe
pourtant la faao considère
l'alimentation à base d'insectes comme
une des solution pour lutter contre la
faim dans le monde car les insectes sont
souvent plus nutritifs que la viande de
bœuf par exemple macéré dans du vinaigre
pu passer au four ils sont prêts à être
saisis à la poêle donc là ça va aller
très vite la
cuisson Miguel s'est lancé dans la
cuisine aux insectes il y a quelques
mois et il vient même de prendre la
présidence de la Fédération française
des producteurs importateurs et
distributeurs
d'insectes
c'est vraiment comme des petits biscuits
Friant c'est c'est vraiment super c'est
c'est vraiment bon là on mange comme ça
voil c'est un goû de
noisette franchement c'est pas
pasagré franchement c'est bon poser sur
un toast de chèvre chaud une alliance
presque naturelle compte ça va faire un
petit peu champre des fois le chèvre il
est employé dans des dans des salades
campagnard des trucs comme ça et qui bon
bah vu que le grillon lui il est
considéré VI dans le bois quand même
donc ça les liens sont quand même
proches donc voilà au salon l'étrangeem
est finalement bien reçu c'est vrai
qu'on est toujours un peu rétissant à
manger des insectes mais cuisiner comme
ça c'est
vraiment ça un petit goût de noisette
c'est un petit goût de c'est vraiment
très bon franchement je pensais pas que
c'était qu'on pouvait manger des
insectes seulement voilà la législation
française ne considère pas les insectes
comme des aliments en France la demande
d'autorisation est en cours à la DGCCRF
mais en attendant Miguel prend des
précautions ça m'est arrivé de faire
signer une décharge pour faire
comprendre à la personne que moi je lui
fais déguster donc l'insecte à mes
dépend mais qu'il n'y a pas
d'autorisation
et ça peut être problématique
quoi au total 1900 espèces d'insectes
seraient comestibles
de quoi varier les
plaisirs et bon appétit si vous venez de
nous rejoindre vous avez goûté vous les
insectes oui oui plusieurs fois
vous aussi Sophie d'ailleurs vous me
disiez pendant le sujetou oui oui j'ai
goûté les grillons ou ça pas beaucoup de
goût mais les grillons poilés quand
c'est faire des spécialistassaisonnement
et léger c'est très très bon et vous
ferez des dégustations àop ce weekend
àop ouais il y en aura c'est pas
incompatible de vouloir les protéger et
de les manger quand même non pas du tout
parce que c'est ces insectes là qui sont
proposés à dégustation c'est des
insectes qui sont élevés pour ça et
c'est justement un des atouts de de
l'insecte dans dans la nourriture
humaine c'est que ça s'élève très très
facilement et qu'il y a un rendement
énorme par rapport à ce qui peut y avoir
comme rendement pour pour de la viande
de bœuf où il me semble qu'il faut 8 kg
pour arriver à 1 kg de matière
consommable pour les insectes c'est du
rapport de 1 pour un à peu près h c'est
finalement écologique en plus de
produire des insectes voilà c'est c'est
un des arguments avancés par les gens
qui prendent l'antomophagie
effectivement ou pour finir le selon
vous les insectes peuvent être des
indicateurs de qualité de
l'environnement c'est ça oui tout à fait
mais le le on on utilise depuis
longtemps les insectes aquatiques pour
évaluer la la qualité du milieu parce
que dès qu'il y a une pollution en fait
ceux qui sont sensibles à la pollution
vont disparaître et mettant du temps à
revenir donc comme ça on peut voir s'il
y a eu une pollution qui s'est passé il
y a longtemps alors que la chimie nous
permet pas de le faire et euh donc
certaines esp s'il y a beaucoup
d'espèces s'il y en a et s'ils sont
nombreux l'environnement est sain voilà
si s'ils sont divers s'ils sont
diversifiés ENIT parce qu'il peut y
avoir une espèce très résistante à la à
la pollution qui du coup pulule donc
c'est c'est un un équilibre entre les
espèces qu'on trouve le nombre d'espèces
qu'on trouve et le nombre d'individus et
si vous voulez tout savoir sur les
insectes rendez-vous à Lopi on vous a
donné les dates tout à l'heure et puis
cette chronique est aussi à revoir sur
notre site internet merci Sophie merci
de ces précisions